the movie is set in the year 1945 with
World War II in Europe having recently
ended it's the time when Denmark is
finally liberated from German occupation
we are then introduced to a sergeant
named Carl Leopold rasmusen who is
watching the German prisoners of War
returning to the Danish Army after 5
years of service in the British
parachute regiment during this Carl
spots one of the German prisoners
carrying a Danish flag which enrages him
as a result he furiously beats him up
and snatches the flag flag away in the
next scene we see the young German
prisoners arrive at a field where they
are addressed by Carl's commanding
officer Captain EB Jensen from the
Danish Pioneer Corps e explains that
they are brought to Denmark for only one
purpose to clear Denmark's West Coast
where the Germans had buried thousands
of landmines in the sand the prisoners
are warned not to expect any sympathy
from the Danes because Denmark is not
their friend following this briefing the
training begins where the young
prisoners are instructed on how to
defuse the land m using their bare hands
this emphasizes the extreme danger
involved as any small mistake would lead
to death as part of their training the
young German soldiers are provided with
real landmines and are tasked with
carrying out the diffusing process in an
abandoned bunker a prisoner named Herman
morbach volunteers to go first and
successfully diffuses a mine
subsequently all the German prisoners
take their turns to diffuse but one of
them fails resulting in a fatal
explosion upon completing their training
the German soldiers are sent to a small
Hut containing a room with several beds
once there they are approached by
Sergeant Carl who expresses his anger at
the war and decides to treat the young
prisoners without sympathy he then lines
them up and asks for their names one by
one amidst this he stumbles upon the
twin brothers Verner and Ernst Lesnar
Ernst instantly gets a slap from the
sergeant for answering on behalf of his
brother following this Carl leads the
prisoners to the sand Dunes revealing an
area marked with black flags he reveals
that a whopping
45,000 mines are hidden there he then
announces that the young prisoners will
only be allowed to return home after
diffusing all of the mines furthermore
he informs them that if they manage to
diffuse six landmines an hour and save
themselves from blowing up they can
anticipate going home within 3 months
Carl also provides them with a map
explaining that each zone is assigned a
number and instructs the boys to keep
the map constantly updated with this
information in mind the young soldiers
start their work they lie down on the
sand dunes and search for the landmines
before carefully diffusing them after
their work the boys rest in their modest
Hut in order to keep the team optimistic
one of the boys named Sebastian talks
about his plans after returning home in
the meantime the twin brothers notice a
local girl playing with her doll across
the street seeing that the girl has food
Ernst approaches her and tries to
befriend her however their interaction
is abruptly interrupted when the girl's
mother shows up and scolds her for
talking to the Germans in the midst of
this Ernst manages to steal a piece of
bread from the child's toy cart which he
later shares with his brother as night
falls Carl instructs everyone to retreat
to their beds and secures the Hut doors
before departing the following day the
young soldiers continue their toil but
circumstances start getting hard as they
are not given food due to post-war
shortages as a result of this the
Germans begin to suffer uer from
malnourishment making it difficult to
deal with the mindes despite this
adversity they are forced to keep
working without any breaks in between
later that night a guy named Helmut
sneaks out of the Hut in search of some
food a fellow group member named vilhelm
notices him but he opts to remain silent
on the next day verer on behalf of his
brother requests Carl for permission for
a leave because Ernst isn't feeling well
and is continuously vomiting however the
sergeant declines their plea compelling
them to continue their labor later on
vilhelm is in the middle of the
diffusing process when he feels nauseous
and vomits on the landmine as a
consequence the land mine explodes
blowing off both of his hands seeing
this some boys hurly carry the crying
vilhelm and take him to the sergeant who
then sends him to a field hospital that
same night all the boys experience
severe stomach ache due to the food that
helmot brought the previous night from a
nearby Barn when Carl shows up in the
morning helmot immediately admits his
fault prompting the sergeant to inspect
the barn upon doing so it turns out that
helmet has stolen the rat feces in Grain
mistaking it as food with this
realization Carl makes the boys Purge
themselves with seawater in order to rid
their bodies of the toxic food I knew
that food tasted like afterwards
Sebastian presents Carl with a wooden
frame explaining that it'll make their
work much easier however the sergeant
dismisses the idea and orders him to go
to bed on the following day Carl visits
the field hospital to check on vilhelms
condition once there a nurse sadly
informs him that vilhelm has succumbed
to his injuries this news saddens the
sergeant and he feels bad for the German
boys after this he goes to their base
camp and steals some food before
returning upon arriving at the West
Coast Carl begins to treat his charges
more kindly he wakes up the boys and
offers them the food the boys are
finally able to fill up their stomachs
after such a long Gap shortly after he
tells tell them the good and the bad
news starting with the good news he
states that he visited the field
hospital and lies that vilhelm is
recovering well however the bad news is
that they are already falling behind
schedule with their work so they now
have to diffuse eight landmines an hour
to catch up back at work Carl allows the
boys to use the wooden frame invented by
Sebastian in order to improve their
productivity while the others continue
diffusing the landmines verer Ernst and
ludvig carry the diffused mines to the
grassy field at top of hill after a
whole day of work the boys return to
their Hut and rest during the night time
Captain AB who has heard the rumors
about Carl stealing food for the boys
brings a group of British soldiers to
abuse and torment the Germans upon
hearing the commotion Carl walks out and
tries to stop the soldiers citing that
they need the boys to wipe out the
entire Coast e stops but he takes the
sergeant to have a little chat in
private the captain accuses him of being
sympathetic towards the Germans and
stealing food for them Carl claims that
he took the food for himself and his dog
not the boys however e remains
unconvinced and points out that Carl is
receiving enough money to afford
sufficient food for himself the next day
during work Ernst discovers that the
landmines are buried one on top of the
other he hurriedly calls out to his twin
brother to warn him but verer doesn't
hear the warning and tragically blows
himself up terrified Ernst rushes to
find his brother but he is nowhere to be
found despite this he is not ready to
accept his brother's death even after
being comforted by the sergeant seeing
his Disturbed State Carl takes him back
to the Hut and asks him to take some
rest assuring him that they'll find his
brother tomorrow afterwards Carl
approaches Sebastian who is gazing at
the sunset he confides in him that he
has not been truthful with the boys and
that vilhelm has passed away in response
Sebastian reveals that he's already
aware of this he also says that what
Carl did was understandable as he did
not want the boys to lose hope as their
conversation unfolds Sebastian injects
some humor and the two gradually
establish a warm and friendly connection
the following day Carl pays a visit to
the base camp and again brings food for
the boys he grants them a leave from
their work allowing them to enjoy the
beach he even joins them in a casual
game of football reveling in the joy of
the moment it's not quite Top Gun but
it'll do in the midst of this two
additional German prisoners arrive there
to join them in their mission of
diffusing landmines ludvig welcomes them
and invites them to join in their fun
after their football match they engage
in a friendly race while Ernst is seen
playing alone with a mouse he found in a
grassy field in the next scene the group
makes their way back to the Hut on their
way Carl tosses a ball towards a
supposedly cleared zone of the beach and
orders his dog to retrieve it oh God
unfortunately the dog triggers a
landmine and is fatally wounded this
incident leaves the sergeant heartbroken
and he thinks that it's the boy's
irresponsibility ludvig who is assigned
to clear that area asserts that he had
indeed disarmed all the landmines and
counted it twice to confirm but Carl
still believes that he miscounted
unfortunately he loses his temper and
once again starts mistreating the boys
he claims that he made a big mistake by
trusting them amidst this tense
atmosphere Helmut begins to laugh
provoking The Rage of the sergeant
believing that he is mocking him Carl
delivers some hard slaps you make me mad
I slap you and warns him against
repeating it following this he forces
them to line up and March close together
across the cleared zones of the beach in
order to confirm that they are safe
later in the day the boys are resting in
their Huts after work when helmet makes
a bold decision to run away he tries to
persuade the others to do the same
because they won't survive here this way
however the rest of the boys refuse to
follow suit Sebastian acting as the
group's leader firmly instructs helmet
to remove such ideas from his mind
asserting that they will be staying
there until their job is done helmet
refuses to comply and decides to leave
alone faced with no other option
Sebastian and his comrades restrain
helmet in his bed and place a ball in
his mouth to keep him quiet a short
while later the local little girl's
mother comes running into the Hut and
pleads for the boy's help to save her
daughter the boys promptly follow the
woman to the restricted area on the
beach where they find the girl playing
meanwhile Carl arrives at the hut and
discovers only Ernst after after
inquiring about the whereabouts of the
other boys the sergeant proceeds towards
the beach where he finds the boys
helping the local woman in her
daughter's rescue a few moments later
erst arrives at the scene and walks
towards the girl without thinking of the
minds he calms the Girl by engaging in a
playful interaction while Sebastian
clears a path for her safe rescue
eventually Sebastian reaches the girl
and Ernst passes her over to him however
Ernst refuses to go back and instead
walks forward through the uncleared
field because of this he meets the same
tragic fate as his twin brother wait why
did he do that witnessing this Carl
becomes emotional and starts treating
the boys kindly again all it takes to
make him kind is a little death he later
approaches The Grieving Sebastian and
reassures him that they will soon be
able to go home he also says that the
group needs Sebastian so he needs to
stay strong from the next day onward the
boys continue their mind clearance work
with Carl also helping them in finishing
their task quickly when one day the four
boys Sebastian ludvig helmet and rodolph
who the hell is rodolph continue
clearing the beach along with the
sergeant while the rest of them load
unexploded mines onto a truck during
this one of the boys inadvertently
tosses a mine that was not properly
diffused into the truck bed of
deactivated Minds this results in a
catastrophic chain reaction that claims
the lives of all seven members of the
group The End oh my God witnessing this
tragic event Carl and the four surviving
boys rush to the site of the explosion
but find no trace of their comrades this
devastating incident leaves the
survivors deeply traumatized in the next
scene Carl fulfills his promise and
sends the remaining Boys Home in a truck
after successfully clearing all the
landmines after this the sergeant
returns to the base camp to speak with e
much to his shock e tells him that he
has sent the four German boys to another
Minefield to join another group of
Germans to diffuse more landmines the
this new field presents even greater
risks as they lack a map and there are a
daunting 72,000 mines to be diffused en
raged by this Revelation Carl asks AB to
allow the four boys to return home as he
had already promised them however the
captain shows no sympathy and claims
that all the Germans must stay until all
the minds are cleared fueled by anger
and determination Carl decides to defy
orders and drives towards the new
Minefield he retrieves the four boys and
drives them towards the German border
once they are 500 M away from the border
Carl instructs the boys to run away the
movie ends with the sergeant watching
the boys run to their freedom subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching